MOM: YOU CAN QUIT ANYTIME,
BUT FOR NOW GIVE IT YOUR ALL!
Flight Leader Kakiyasu!
Hisone Amakasu has made contact!
Um, Flight Leader Kakiyasu,
I'm sorry this has gotten out of hand.
I'm still holding onto my life,
but I at this rate, I might lose it
before I can apologize.
I don't care about an apology!
Where are you flying now?!
How did you get a cell signal
from inside the OTF?!
I got it! It's the rear riser headpiece!
I can't pinpoint their location,
but I've confirmed a signal coming from
the OTC prototype 16 safety visor!
Maybe we're receiving correspondence
because Amakasu has the headpiece!
Have the instrumentation unit determine
the OTF's position now!
As soon as we have it,
send fighter planes to escort them!
-Amakasu!
-Yes!
Are you ready?
I need you to do exactly as I direct you.
-You got that?
-Yes!
You've got the headpiece on, right?
Press the button on the back of it.
Y-You mean this?
-The OTF control program is activated.
-Next!
Touch the PT-V2 module displayed
on the visor to start it up!
Um...
FOXTROT
It has changed from
Hotel mode to Foxtrot mode.
She did that?
It's beautiful.
Third Class Amakasu.
Do you remember the landing operation?
Y-Yes.
I'm supposed to rhythmically push my toes
toward my stomach,
and--
-Cancel! Tell me how to cancel!
-Third Class Amakasu?!